[Musique]
suite numéro deux dans ses airs anciens
d'orchestre les élèves répètent une
composition d'ottorino respighi chef
italien du 20e siècle
ils font partie de leur caste recréer
chaque année par le conservatoire de
montigny le bretonneux
on essaie d'avoir une programmation qui
est la plus variée possible à la fois
pour le public est à la fois aussi pour
les élèves pour qu'ils puissent jouer
différents différents styles alors au
programme on a des oeuvres de schubert
mais aussi une musique
deux bandes originales des compositeurs
georges delerue qui était composée pour
le film game bien fou près de quarante
musiciens élèves et professeurs du
conservatoire font partie de l'orchestré
symphonique 5 à 6 répétitions sont
nécessaires pour se coordonner et
surtout découvrir leurs chefs
d'orchestre invités pour l'occasion
cette année ils sont dirigés par
laetitia trouvé il faudrait une couleur
métier dur où je m'étais quelque chose
d'un peu plus velours voyez ça vous
parle
texture à laetitia trouver dirigé les
orchestres du concepteur de vincennes et
aussi des orchestres professionnels bien
évidemment les élèves se prennent au jeu
et c'est aussi une grande importance
d'avoir un chef invité d'avoir pour les
élèves une tête nouvelle à chaque fois
parce que c'est des exigences
différentes et c'est un peu comme les
gros orchestre qui les orchestres
invités qui change de chef mais là les
élèves ont aussi changé de chef
d'orchestre conclure à une après-midi de
concerts à montigny le bretonneux des
harmonies et orchestres à cordes et à
vent seront aussi à découvrir
[Musique]
bon